Angie Augustin est sur un nuage car elle
interprète une de ses chorégraphies de
stellafro dans la version canadienne de
Just Dance 2023 un populaire jeux vidéo
d'Ubisoft c'est sûr que c'est un moment
de fierté c'est un moment que je sais
même pas comment décrire tellement que
c'était plein d'émotions mais j'ai eu un
petit peu les larmes aux yeux pour être
bien à naître
l'histoire D'Angio Augustin alias citron
rose est inspirante né à Montréal de
parents haïtiens cette autodidacte a eu
la piqûre pour les danses africaines dès
le début de sa vingtaine le style de
danse afro elle en est devenu obsédé
vous cherchez des tutoriels sur Youtube
et chercher des vidéos sur Instagram je
les enregistré puis j'étais comme ok ce
mouvement là faut que je le comprenne
faut que je l'aie comment qu'il
s'appelle ok j'essayais de trouver des
gens de ce pays là qui le faisait je
cherchais les variantes j'étais vraiment
ça me stimulait tellement que je voulais
vraiment me perfectionner là-dedans
depuis toujours j'ai dit
Augustin est aujourd'hui une des
principales danseuses de la rappeuse
saramée aussi créatrice de contenu elle
compte 650 000 abonnés sur TikTok tout
se succès à attiré l'attention d'Ubisoft
pour qui est la mise en chorégraphie
woman de dojack
parce que au quotidien moi j'enseigne de
l'afro de type féminin donc j'ai des
groupes de femmes peu importe facile de
leur niveau de danse que je réunis puis
je fais des chorégraphies pour essayer
de
booster leur estime personnel pour
essayer de leur permettre de reconnecter
avec leur corps
la danseuse chorégraphe et créatrice de
contenu est sur une lancée et elle
compte bien continuer de partager son
amour pour la danse afro je me sens
vraiment choyé d'avoir eu cette place
que Ubisoft m'a donné la place de
pouvoir indirectement faire un statement
dans le sens que je représente un petit
peu la diversité de Montréal si on voit
Montréal en arrière de moi et c'est si
beau mais attention n'est pas une vie
Augustin qui veut il faudra vous exercer
avant d'atteindre son niveau
[Musique]